previously in the suicide squad one
minute and 27 seconds of opening
previously ons i want to meet the one
maybe two people that are going into the
show having not seen the suicide squad
and ask them why what brought you here i
cherish peace with all my heart i don't
care how many men women and children i
need to kill to get it watching the
suicide squad scenes out of context like
this makes it seem like the suicide
squad was better than it actually was
and you for feeding me lies peacemaker
you're shot and a building falls on you
and all you have to replace is a
clavicle joe appears to be under the
mistaken illusion that peacemaker's
ridiculous survival can be redeemed by
directly acknowledging said
ridiculousness it cannot casting someone
you can't see is your lead
you're a superhero i feel like this
cheeky reveal is supposed to crack me up
but
it just feels too asinine orpin all at
best but no was i supposed to say bainl
hey guys did the british guy write this
script or something dude i'm [ __ ]
famous not that famous aquaman he's
famous man who just criticized john cena
for being too bulky to be a superhero
uses jason momoa as his next superhero
reference he starts fish let's take it a
step too far for the aquaman or the fish
because i'm leaning more the ladder in
scared that peacemaker is leaning toward
the former i made a vow to have peace no
matter how many people i have to kill to
get it sure i laughed when i heard this
line in the trailer for the suicide
squad i even let out a slight snicker
when i heard it in the theater but oh
man it's hardly i can do this all day
levels of reusable hmm a peacemaker
musical though
i'm thinking i can just go why not oh i
don't know maybe the bomb inside your
head i think peacemaker's the one that
really needs to watch the previous leons
here one minute and 21 seconds of cena
shaking patrick pelvising finish rocking
absolute what the [ __ ] and i think i
liked it however with that being said
this is still a minute and 21 seconds of
opening credits so my hands are tied
outside of the opening credits episode
contains no lachlan monroe why do motels
still exist whoever thought having an
outside entrance like this was a good
thing you know what college dorm rooms
set up like this can [ __ ] off as well
and you might ask but what about
apartments condos all houses and i will
kindly ask you to [ __ ] off and let me
gripe about motels i thought i was going
to be like james bond now does this look
like james bond to you i mean maybe like
man with a golden gun era james bond
what is an octopussy anyway i along with
every bond fan have been asking that
question for 39 years to no avail what's
wrong just worried skip
yeah this
is just a paycheck
it's just for now you and me and anyone
who's ever watched a tv show knows it's
not thinking doves can be kept in coops
i mean technically they can but a lot of
dubs do not get along so if you go the
cupro you're looking to get a lot of
dove blood on your hands just call him a
pigeon do your columba homework before
designating your nicknames having
whatever the this is i'm going with
rubber band balls as a decorative
display
or you could use your already protected
fist
i have low blood sugar okay so i'm dizzy
jonathan's excuse every time he wants to
swipe some of my you stash somehow makes
its way into this episode hey dude
you're eating four-year-old out of my
fridge relying on your hearing to tell
if something is disgusting instead of
your sense of taste glad to be here
ready to kick some ass sir leota's ass
kissing goes on for all the sometime
point is just cause some other dumb
[ __ ] out there with shears
clipping roses doesn't mean you aren't
yeah peacemaker would be an actual hero
at tv sins you let somebody shoot you
it's like i invited him to come shoot me
dad
main character if a tv show has a father
cliche you know i asked you to cancel my
phone service so it's still on i've been
paying for service for years because you
forgot since that cell phone still had
power i'd be more worried about the
massive electric bill that you've racked
up for the last four years oh my god
he's hugging me i can't tell if the
eagle hugging is the silliest or coolest
thing i've ever seen i'm gonna send it
just to be safe the only desk was sun
take the one in the middle is the leak
that much of a burden can she not just
move the desk what agency did you get
transferred from
[ __ ] you how name of the agency that
produces my sex tape and this other
member of the team rat catcher she
controls rats this pilot is actually 25
callbacks from the suicide squad and
considering it was written by james gunn
too it really feels like all sorts of
peacemaker basin by locking them in a
crate for 24 hours with nothing but
starving rats
this overreacts on for all of the why
are we even laughing sometime this one
has full body force field
and this has sonic blast capabilities
wait these helmets actually do things
and what the [ __ ] does the one that he
gave to the taxi driver do and if that's
one of the few that do nothing why did
he bother taking it to corto maltese
instead of one of these bad boys hey
sweet cheeks
can you take my order real quick
peacemaker survives this
zoodles are zucchini noodles not making
them sound any better christopher you
don't have to be happy with this detail
but you do have to treat your fellow
soldiers with respect we've just
listened to these people mock his
clothing and choice of pet name but he's
the one that has to learn to play nice i
hate all of these people think that's my
friend gut chase's younger brother
he has mental issues might as well throw
mental issue jokes onto the pile that
already consists of racism homophobia
and sexism the show is like a game of
inappropriate bingo and it's one spot
away from winning and yes all of these
awful attitudes are the point of the
show and you can definitely mine comedy
gold with edgy subject matter but you
actually have to be funny and when
you're not like most of this episode
it's just straight up cringe so darcy on
the first target you're a senator don't
look at it here then why did you [ __ ]
bring it here in the first place what do
you intend to use this hq4 if it isn't
to brief the team on their highly
illegal assignments
get my little t-shirt i will add one
million sins if we don't see this guy
again suffering through the scene alone
is bad enough but the sin hammer shall
provide an additional righteous
pummeling if it's all for naught hey
you're invited if you win i don't
want to come to your abortion man
somebody not only chose to write this
exchange but also decided to pay two
people to act it out so that millions of
other people could watch it
[ __ ] this [ __ ] survives this yeah
his friend gets the pre-children kicked
out of him but this guy gets away
consequence-free
you know i was thinking at least this
show wasn't trying to force some
[ __ ] potential romance between
peacemaker and harcourt but here we are
well that's escalated quickly night baby
girl
night mom
[Music]
oh this
this is my jam passing up night songs
for wake me when it's over i'm no expert
but i believe that's a different type of
amplification device
[Music]
seriously what the [ __ ] is this show is
it a comedy an action show an action
comedy show with hate speech thrown in
to add flavor beaded curtains since we
find out this woman's actually a robot
or something that's supposed to kill
peacemaker i guess they could have
arranged the place to fit in more with
christopher's personal interest the 80s
hair being dtf having a hair metal vinyl
collection but what the [ __ ] is up with
the beaded curtains were those even
popular in the 80s that definitely seems
more like a 70s thing and they sure as
hell aren't popular now outside of palm
reader offices why are the beaded
curtains waiting to make your attack
until you're in plain sight of your
intended victim it only took the show a
little over 42 minutes to get to some
version of fun yay
christopher just so happened to pick the
helmet that had a specific power he
needed tonight to save his life i mean
what if he'd pick the one with x-ray
vision these spontaneously coagulating
stab wounds okay yep eagley's getting to
sit off i'm only human guys this one
will give you scabies confusing editing
room floor with crediting and bore
i need the secure packaging of jockeys
my boys need a house
domestic situation known as project
butterfly beware you know what you're
being an [ __ ] all right you know what
i do with [ __ ] i lick them okay what
can i get you
hey you don't have any goldfish crackers
up there don't mean to be coy
oh my god could you at least take your
helmet off you're gonna get dressing all
over it you do not cover your face you
are not mandalorian we're like simon and
garfunkel and somehow you turned me into
garfunkel i don't even know what that
means aren't garfunkel what's wrong with
art garfunkel he has a beautiful voice
he's got an amazing voice he can put a
harmony to anything but what i'm saying
is that you turned me into hand simon
controls him that's because simon writes
the [ __ ] songs
he's the better one
scotty doesn't know that fiona and me
doing in my van every sunday
and his name is john c